>> From the library of
congress, in Washington DC.
>> So next up here at the National
Book festival we'll be hearing a
portion of LOBA by
Verónica Murguía.
Verónica is a Mexican born, fantasy
writer who has won multiple prizes
for her children's
literature and novels.
In 2005 her book AULIYA, A-U-L-I-Y-A
was name one of the books
of the year by Banca del
Libro of Venezuela as well
as being translated in German,
Italian, and Portuguese.
That's three more languages
than I know, because I know two.
Her fantasy novel, which we'll hear
from today LOBA was awarded the
Grand Angular prize in 2013,
from Spain, and we cannot
wait to hear some of it today.
After the talk, you can have
Miss Murguía Sign a book for you
at the book signing area which is
down, all the way down the hallway
in the book signing area from
3 o'clock to 4 o'clock today.
I'm so excited to hear from this
book, it just sounds like it's going
to be so interesting, and so
to welcome us to the stage is,
if you could please
welcome Verónica Murguía.
[ Applause ]
>> Verónica Murguía: Hi guys,
you have to be patient with me
because Loba has not been
translated into English, so,
and it's a really thick
and big book,
so I thought maybe I could
talk to you about my books.
The most recent books that I
wrote that are for little children
and maybe I could talk to you
about what does a writer do,
because most people think
that writers are very inspired
and they just come up with the
stories, but I'm not like that,
I have to work a lot at it because
I'm not very smart, but I try,
and the book I'm going to talk to
you about is a book that I really
like because is a book for children.
The name is "Rani", that
the name of an elephant.
"Timbo", that's the name of my cat.
My cat's real name is Timo, but
I put Timbo, I don't know why,
maybe to preserve his privacy,
and "La hija de Tláloc",
that means "The daughter
of Tláloc".
Tláloc is the God of rain in
ancient pre-Hispanic mythology.
And I decided to write
this story because I go
around the zoo in Mexico City.
The zoo is in the middle of a
forest that is called "Chapultepec".
It's like Central Park, you
know Central Park in New York?
You do. Well is like kind of
like Central Park but it's older,
and since before the Spanish
people came to Mexico,
it was there, and it
had a zoo there.
It was kind of not a very nice
zoo because it had animals,
but also had people in it,
because the ancient emperors
of Mexico wanted people in their
zoo, they were not very nice.
And I don't know if you know
but Mexico has a very dramatic
story-- History, and story also.
When the Spanish people came they
found the ancient Aztec empire,
they clashed, and the built a
city on top of another city.
So my city is very old.
The first persons that
lived in that city,
lived in it about 2000 years
ago, so it's a really old city,
and it was built on top of a
lake, and when the Spanish came
to live there, they drained the
lake and we don't have water.
But that's just one of the things
that I wanted to write about,
because in the same place where the
pre-Hispanic emperor had his zoo,
the modern people of Mexico
built another zoo with animals.
And in there, there lived three
elephants that I used to go and look
at them, and I liked them very much.
But I think the space they
had them in, it was too small
because the elephants use to move
like this, the three of them,
very close so each other
and they were kind of sad,
they didn't like being there, so
I imagined the talks they had.
What would the tell each other?
Their story about being
an elephant in a zoo.
And I imagined that one of them
would not like being there,
the young one, born in captivity.
I'm talking about real animals,
I just imagined the
dialogues between them.
The younger one was born in the zoo,
but the other ones were in a circus,
and a very poor circus
that went around the county
and they were badly mistreated,
and they were rescued by the people
in the zoo and put there in the
cage, but they weren't happy either
because I think they wanted
to live in a wider place.
But I imagine the dialogues
like something
like the aunts telling the small
one - It's better to be born here
than being in the circus, because
in the circus you have to work
for your food, and in the zoo you
just have to move your trunk around
and just say hello to the kids and
that's the way you earn your living.
And I invented that my cat
would live in the street
and then go into the zoo at night.
He would creep into the zoo
and talk to the animals.
And one day the cat got
into the hyenas' cage
and the hyenas were very happy to
see him but they got carried away
and bit his ear off
and the elephants heard
and they were very
angry and they said --
If you ever, ever touch this cat
again we will break down our cage
and go and slap you with our trunks.
And the hyenas were really scared
and they promised never
to touch the cat again.
And the cat would go and
live with the elephants.
And the cat would go out during the
day time to see what was happening
around the zoo and he saw a little
Indian girl, and this part is true,
a little Indian girl who
didn't have a place to live
that was selling candy in
a corner, and he would see
that little Indian every day,
and the girl was there
selling her candy.
In front of the place
where this girl used
to sell her candy it's
a very big museum
where the big gods of
the Aztecs are kept.
There is a huge, enormous,
gigantic statue
of a god whose name is Tláloc
and he was the god of rain.
And the god Tláloc in my story
is the father of that little girl
because that little girl
in disguise is a goddess.
And one day she was selling her
candy and one man tried not to pay
and to slap her and the little cat
got really angry and bit the man.
And the goddess was thankful to
the cat and gave him a candy.
A candy that would give
him all he wished for,
just once, not eternally.
But the cat was so
happy living in the --
around the zoo with his friends
that he didn't have any
wish for anything special.
Cats don't drive cars, they don't
need houses, they don't need us,
they just need food
and just have fun.
He is a fast cat who made fun of
dogs, he would bite a dog's tail
and go running, so he didn't need
anything and he hid his candy.
But one day when the youngest of
the elephants was really, really sad
and bored being there in a cage,
the aunts told her - don't be sad,
because we elephants, we
have a story a nice story.
We used to have princes on our
backs and carry them around.
In India, princes used
to go on top of us.
And this that I'm about to tell
you is true, the absolute true.
Harun al-Rashid, this
guy that appears in the -
"1001 Knight" you call it?
No, "Arabian Knights", that the way
you call the book in English right?
Well, that guy Charlemagne,
the emperor of France,
gave him an elephant as a gift,
and this elephant was very
brave and he died in battle.
He and this elephant was the first
elephant to ever be in France,
and the people were really
in awe of this elephant
because it was very smart too.
So the aunts tell the little
elephant the story and she wants
to carry a prince in her back.
So what she does is that the,
she tells the little cat,
the cat gives her the candy and she
goes to a statue that is in Mexico,
is a statue that is
between two very big avenues
and there's a prince there.
A prince that when he was 17
years old, he defended the city
against the Spanish and he was
very brave, and the elephant,
because of the magic of the goddess,
could carry him around for a night
because the statue came to life.
That's the story I wrote and I
will tell you why I wrote it.
I wrote it because one of the
things that makes me very angry
in my country is to see
children working in the streets,
and there are many children
working in the streets,
and they have to earn money
to eat and I don't like that.
Because children should be
the way you are right now.
Listening to people tell
stories, playing, reading,
waiting for your parents to buy
you a book, going to school.
That's what children
should do, not work,
but there are many children
working in the streets of my city
and I get really angry at that.
So I wrote this story so the child
in the story would have power
and be important and
do whatever she wanted.
And I also wrote the story because
I like animals and I like the zoo
but I'm always questioning myself,
if zoos are a good
option for animals.
I really don't know.
Any of you know?
What would you like if you
were an elephant to live
in the jungle or to live in the zoo?
You tell me.
The jungle yeah!
I think they would -- all of them
would like to be in the jungle.
Who else has an opinion?
You? The jungle.
You? Yeah!
Think. Would you rather
be in the jungle even
if you didn't have any kids waving
at you and giving you candy?
Yeah, well that's what I think.
And now I ask you --
You like the zoo?
You like it?
Yeah! That's a very tough
thing to answer because I
like to go watch the animals but
maybe they don't like being there,
so I don't know what to do, that's
why I wrote the book so I could talk
to children and children
would tell me what they think.
What do you think?
Would you like to live
in a city without a zoo?
You like zoos right?
So what would you do?
Just have pets?
Who has a pet here?
You have a pet.
Everybody.
Would you like your pets
to be free in the jungle?
No, no, no me neither, I have
my cat, I want my cat with me.
So is a very hard question, I
don't know how to answer it.
So that's why I wrote the book.
Yes --
[ Inaudible question ]
What?
Yes! That's what I think but that
maybe what you're saying can be
applied to the zoos.
Make animals happy in the zoos.
So, for example -- No
more Orcas in Sea World,
no matter if they are beautiful.
They are too big to
be kept in a pool.
Don't you think that?
So, we have to make animals
happy, we all agree on that.
And we have to make all children
happy too, don't you think so?
So that's why I wrote the book.
Do you have any questions for me?
Like, I don't know -- Is it hard to
be a children's author in Mexico,
or the name of my cat or
if any of you knows Spanish
or Spanish words --
You know Spanish?
How many words?
Do you know how to speak Spanish?
[ Inaudible ]
You may not listen but she's fluent
in Spanish so there's one person
who can read the book
if she wants to --
two persons that can read
the book if you want to,
three, you also speak Spanish?
And you too?
All of you speak Spanish?
Y por qué no me dijeron
que hablaban español?
Because I am here speaking
in English and English,
is not my -- I don't know.
>> I am Spanish.
>> Verónica Murguía:
Who's Spanish?
Who is? You're Spanish?
>> I speak Spanish.
>> Verónica Murguía: Tell
me something in Spanish.
Anything, something in
Spanish, the name of your cat
if you have a cat or a dog.
>> I can read a poem.
>> Verónica Murguía: Great.
You know any poems
by heart in Spanish?
>> Yes.
>> Verónica Murguía: Can
you please tell me your poem?
>> Yes, Ok so this poem is the
one that I learned in after care.
>> Verónica Murguía: Ok.
>> Grillos, luciérnagas,
ranas traen ruidos y color el búho
pide silencio con sus ojos de farol.
>> Verónica Murguía:
Ah that's great!
[ Applause ]
Someone else?
Please another poem in Spanish?
The book's title is Rani, which
is the name of a little elephant,
Timbo which is the name of my
cat and la hija de Tláloc,
that means the daughter
of a god, ok?
Yes?
[ Inaudible question ]
My advice to write is
just to go and sit down
and read a lot and then write.
But read like a crazy person.
Who reads a lot here?
Great, great.
You should keep on reading all
the time even when you grow up.
You read, you read, you read
and then after reading a lot,
you feel like you have
to write something.
Anyone else?
Another question?
A question about my
city which is so old.
[ Inaudible question ]
>> I live, I was born in La
Colonia Condesa, but now the place
where I was born, the hospital
that I was born in was torn down,
and now there's nothing
there and I live
in La Colonia Napoles
in very noisy place.
[ Inaudible question ]
You live where?
You live in a nicer place
than the place I live in.
But I love my city even
though isn't very pretty.
I don't know, it's like having a
crazy aunt that you love dearly
but dresses badly, that's how
I feel about my city -- yes?
More questions?
>> Why, well, what did your, like
what other books did you write?
>> Verónica Murguía: Other books?
I wrote this about my
favorite animal beside my cat,
which are bats.
Because bats are really cool
and bats kill the most
dangerous animal on earth.
Do you know which is the most
dangerous animal on earth?
Mosquito, that's -- no he's great --
let's give him a hand please
[applause] he knew the answer,
it's not an easy answer.
If you ask some adults -- What
animal is the most dangerous animal,
they will tell you a
spider or whatever--
they don't know, mosquitos are
really bad and bats eat mosquitoes
like crazy, so I love them, so I
wrote this book -- The Secret Pet.
It's about a very friendly bat
who is friends with a girl -- yes.
[ Inaudible question ]
I can't hear you, I will go
down because I can't hear you.
[ Inaudible question ]
Scorpions are dangerous,
but not like mosquitoes
because there are hundreds
of thousands of -- Another question.
>> What do you like about your book?
>> Verónica Murguía: What
do I like about my book?
The cat and the bat and
I like all the animals.
I like children, I like animals.
I love the things that
appear in my books, so-- yes?
What inspired me to write the book
about the goddess was a little girl
selling candy and what inspired me
to write The Secret Pets are bats
because I really like them I think
that they are really pretty.
I saw one that fell from the tree
in the morning, he walked very badly
like this -- but then when he
flew away, it was so beautiful.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Question ]
In my children's books
there aren't many sad parts,
there are exiting parts or
a little bit scary parts.
But the saddest part maybe is
in this very thick book that is
for young adults -- a father
dies and is really bad.
Yes? My favorite animal
besides the bat is the cat.
I love cats, but I also loves dogs,
I think dogs are really nice -- Yes?
What?
He asked me if I am a scary,
how do you say -- scaredy-cat?
And I am, I am.
Yes?
Wow! You bought it.
I'm going to sign it there and I'm
going to make you a special drawing.
Ok? I hope you like --
You read in Spanish?
Great, great!
We have only 5 my more minutes.
Nobody wants to -- Somebody
wants to say a poem?
Oh there --
>> Not a poem but a question.
Is your book, what's
your book "Loba" about?
>> Verónica Murguía: "Loba" is
about a princess, but not a princess
that uses dresses or anything.
It's about a princess that,
she doesn't believe in dragons
and she hates the idea of magic and
thinks that magic is superstition,
and her father thinks that too, and
magic is forbidden in her country.
And then, one day, a dragon appears
and burns everything down in a city
and she has to go check
if those things
that people are saying are
true and she finds the dragon.
That's what the book is about.
It's about dragons and unicorns,
a very ferocious unicorn
because unicorns are not very sweet.
I read a lot of books of
medieval history and the books
in medieval history explain to us
that unicorns are very ferocious.
So that's the book about, the war
between the unicorn and the dragon
and I like my dragon very much
but I like the unicorn better.
That's what "Loba" is about.
Yes?
>> The question you were -- the book
you were talking about -- during --
is it translated into English?
>> Verónica Murgía: No, that's why
I was so scared to talk to you guys
because none of my books are
translated, and for me is very hard
to talk to you and go tell
you things about my books
because is very hard for
you to know the books
because they haven't
been translated,
they are not in book stores.
So it was a little scared for
me, but now is all right --
no, they are not translated.
>> Is there a chapter book?
>> Verónica Murguía: No.
>> Ok.
>> Verónica Murguía: I'm sorry.
>> I was very interested
in both of your books.
>> Verónica Murguía: If I ever get
one translated maybe you can give me
your e-mail and I will write to
you and I will send you one, ok?
>> Ok, thank you.
>> Verónica Murguía: So, I
think I have to say goodbye, no?
Ah no, there are two minutes.
Yes?
>> ¿Por qué no lees
tantito en español?
>> Verónica Murguía: Ah yes!
I will read from -- I
will read in Spanish
so you can just hear the rhythm.
I'm going to read from my
book of the dragon, ok?
Just for a few minutes.
This is when the dragon wakes up
because the dragon was sleeping,
so you just can hear
a little Spanish.
Wait, as you see I don't
read my books very often
because I can't find
it -- but -- ok.
This is about a falcon.
El fuego ardía quedamente
en la habitación de Soledad.
Ala Gris el halcón de la joven
miraba desde su percha la cama donde
dormían su dueña y
Edurne la vieja nodriza.
Soledad había comprado el
halcón, un neblí todavía pollo,
a un mercader que trataba
con aves de cetrería.
El mercader, un árabe elegante y
taciturno que parecía conocer el
idioma de las aves, las transportaba
en nau de infieles desde Aljaviva.
Elegisteis bien señora,
es un macho,
pero sabrá ser tan
audaz como las hembras.
Cuando termine de crecer tendrá la
alas más cortas que los halcones
noruegos que tanto le
gustan a vuestro padre,
pero os aseguro que será
más rápido que ellos.
Yo mismo lo robé del nido,
aunque no tenía casi plumas
quiso volar y herirme.
El árabe sonrió y sus dientes
brillaron en la cara morena y
curtida por el sol
y el aire del mar.
Tened paciencia con él, dijo
antes de recoger su paga.
Soledad miró el vuelto
tibio que piaba en sus manos,
a pesar de su ligereza y su
pequeñez el pollo estiraba las
patas y buscaba asirle
lo dedos con las garras.
Traía los parpados cosidos.
Soledad pasó casi toda la noche
con el halcón sobre el regazo
arrullándolo y cantándole en voz
baja Luego lo metió en una jaula
preparada con un nido de trapos
lavados y lo alimentó con papillas
de carne de tórtola.
Lo primero que Ala Gris vió en
el mundo fue el rostro de Soledad
cuando ésta cortó los hilos
que le cerraban los ojos.
Para el halcón no habría nunca
un sol más brillante que esa cara
huesuda y esa mirada verde y atenta.
Thank you very much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.